PROFESSOR: One of
the things that's
different about a
recitation like this
is that you're really
coaching students as opposed
to talking at them.
So it takes a little bit
of a different mindset.
In a normal recitation, you
prepare 50 minutes of material.
And you would go in,
and you'd be prepared
to lecture for 50 minutes.
In a recitation like this, you
have to be much more flexible.
You have to think about, how
far do I let the students go?
Do I need to go intervene or let
them work it out a little bit?
Sometimes it's
important for students
to really struggle
a little bit to see
what the central issue is, but
letting them struggle too long
is not productive.
So it's very useful,
at that point,
to step in and try to help.
I like to think of it as
coaching rather than telling.
If you were teaching
students or athletes
how to play soccer or
baseball, you wouldn't just
tell them about it.
You would go out and show them.
You would watch how they do it.
You would correct big mistakes.
As that got better, you'd
correct small mistakes.
And that's really
the way to think
about a recitation like this,
that you're coaching them,
you're helping shape the
students' understanding
so that they can become,
hopefully, as expert
as you are in the material.
So most of us are
used to knowing
what's going to happen in the
50 minutes in the classroom.
So you prepare a certain
amount of material.
You expect to go in and
present that material.
You might run a little
short or a little long,
but there aren't
any big surprises.
When you run an active
recitation like this, well,
what I typically do is
I prepare more problems
than I think I'll need,
because I don't know
how many I will actually use.
And sometimes I
use three or four,
and sometimes we
may only use one.
And so one of the things
you have to be prepared for
is to adapt on the fly.
You've got to be willing to be
flexible and work a little bit
without a net, because you're
just not quite sure what's
going to happen.
And I've seen this in
classroom instruction using
active techniques as well, where
I've asked a concept question
and discovered, through
this immediate feedback,
that students have no idea
what I'm talking about.
Well, it would just be
foolish at that point
to plow ahead and keep
talking about this thing they
don't know about.
You really have to
adapt and figure out,
what have I done wrong?
How can I make this
concept clearer,
because I haven't
really done a good job.
This certainly is
a lead compensator,
but I almost always write it
in-- a really good problem
in recitation is one
that's not tricky
but that is likely to expose
a misconception that students
commonly have.
So if you've taught
a class for a while,
you may discover
that students often
make the same kind of error
when looking at a problem.
And if that's the case,
then a very good thing to do
is to present a problem where
they have the opportunity
to make that mistake.
You don't want them
to make the mistake,
but if they do
make that mistake,
it's then an opportunity
for teaching, right?
It's a teaching
moment where you can
explain why that might
seem like the right answer,
and why it's, in fact, not,
and correct that misconception.
One of the things I really
like about this approach
is that it's just fun.
It's much more fun
to spend 50 minutes
coaching students, talking
with them, chatting with them,
getting to know
them a little bit,
understanding what they don't
understand than it is to just
talk at them for 50 minutes.
So all other things
being equal, I'd
much prefer to do the
stand up recitation
than a conventional recitation.
Of course, what really
matters is the outcome,
but I do think the
outcomes are better.
So in this case, it's
a win-win situation.
I really enjoy
it, and I actually
wouldn't do it any
other way in the future.